last year the average salary in Silicon
Valley was over one hundred and ninety
five thousand dollars even interns can
rake in upwards of six grand a month the
fight for top tech talent is brutal so
companies ply their employees with
endless perks on top of their impressive
salaries let's look at the seven most
ridiculous perks at face book number
seven I've got gourmet food courts and
private chefs across campus serving
everything from smoked pork shoulder to
kale and quinoa and all of its free my
jam when I first started was the BBQ pet
that was ridiculous it's soup of the
brisket not the healthiest thing but
pretty delicious
oh and the noodle bar and there's always
this giant room full of free local
organic things to eat number six imagine
if you could get in better shape at work
than at your local gym sorry Ron moving
our meetings are for I'm getting huge Oh
rock climbing wall I didn't even see you
there this is Mark Zuckerberg climbing
the rock don't be silly
mark's climbing walls are in his
backyard we do a few different things
here we have open climbing time that's
free for employees or interns we also do
some classes where we teach people and
instruct upon rock climbing techniques
number five notice the abundance of eye
candy everywhere you look if you need to
let out some stress before a conference
call and paint some happy little trees
just go to the analog research lab we
have silkscreen facilities these are all
resources for employees and resident
artists alike to come in and express
themselves number four man it's hard
walking across the office fortunately
Facebook has bikes
lots of them if you get a flat stop by
the bike shop and get it fixed the cost
just parts it's really convenient to hop
on a bicycle provided by Facebook any to
to kind of roll up and down campus it's
way faster than walking number three
by far my favorite benefit like the
music around common space - it's like a
dream come true you actually come here
you know within two minutes and play
something kind of think about stuff
solve the problems of my head and then
go back and implement them number two no
need to wait in line for an overpriced
crappy haircut just get an artisanal
trim at the on-campus barber shop number
one no one can mess with you for using
facebook at work
everyone at Facebook spends a lot of
time on Facebook every day I am on
Facebook 24/7 and I'm not driving I'm on
Facebook actually turns out that
Facebook's a pretty powerful
productivity tool as well
Facebook is thought of nearly everything
but what's missing for somebody like Ted
Diggs massaging my shoulders I took a
drone I feel like a lot more getting
drones these days I wish every employee
could have their own drone I would love
to have a little cricket stadium on
campus somewhere and we definitely have
to say a swimming pool ah see they don't
have everything though rumor has it
swimming pools are coming next year when
Facebook answer new Frank Gehry addition
across the road feeling wide yet
subscribe